In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for September 12th, on which we commemorate, the leave
taking of the nativity of the Theotokos and the Holy Hyromarter atonomos of Italy.
On the 12th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hyromarter atonomos.
Atonomos was a bishop in Italy, when the violent persecution unleashed by the Emperor Diocletian
broke out in the year 303. He fled from Italy and found refuge in a Bithinian village called
Sorios, in the easternmost part of the Gulf of Nicomedia, where he was welcomed by a Christian
called Cornelius. When he had been there for quite a long time,
Autonomos decided to build a small church dedicated to the Archangel Michael
and to ordain Cornelius, Deacon. Cornelius took care of the church and of the faithful who gathered
around it, while Autonomos went to spread the word of God in Lyconia and Isaria.
And on his return to Sorios, he ordained Cornelius, priest.
Around this time, the Emperor Diocletian arrived in Nicomedia, angry that the persecution had not
discouraged the Christians and with an animosity against Autonomos who was a well-known preacher
of the Gospel. The Holy Bishop had to flee yet again, and on this occasion he evangelized the towns
on the shores of the Black Sea. Sometime later, he returned to consecrate Cornelius Bishop,
and then tireless as ever, he set off for the western parts of Asia Minor to root out idolatry
and to encourage the growth of the faith. On his return to Sorios, he settled in a neighboring village
where he planted the faith and baptized the inhabitants. One day, these newly-illumant Christians
rushed full of zeal into the idol's temple and threw down all the statues. The pagans were
determined to take vengeance, but bided their time until the Bishop came to celebrate the holy
mysteries in the little church at Sorios. Then they stormed in with sticks, stones, and other weapons,
and killed everyone they could lay hands on. The blessed Autonomos was slain as he stood before
the holy table so that resembling our Savior, it was his own life that he offered in sacrifice.
The few faithful who escaped death buried his body which remains in corrupt. His holy relics
used to rest in a church built at the place of his martyrdom. Through the prayers of our holy
fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.